hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to damn it
rival and why do you keep showing up
here don't you know I'm running out of
jokes I mean how many times can I say
the same thing
you look like you're searching for an
Oscar we know you can act so why don't
you pick movies that let you your improv
czar funny but not needed in every
single movie you do and what's this a
movie where he plays a ten-year-old
trapped in a man's body
sheesh I'm running out of stuff guys I
mean what can I say about a bad Robin
Lane's movie that I can't say about all
the other bad Robin Williams movies I
mean Who am I supposed to make fun of
the director hello new target practice
yeah that's right one of the most
influential directors of all time
Francis Ford Coppola directed this can
you believe it doesn't even sound real
Francis Ford Coppola the director of The
Godfather directed a movie where rather
lames is a ten-year-old in a man's body
unless this is some sort of symbolic
biography this is obviously going to
fail I mean it just doesn't make sense
it's like Alfred Hitchcock directing
Rainbow Brite or Stan Lee Cooper
directing happy gilmore
or mine Scorsese directing Hugo okay
that was awesome but you get the idea
you never would have guessed this guy
would do anything like this in a million
years you broke my heart Ford
you broke my heart so let's not waste
any time
let's take a look at Francis Ford
Coppola's Jack I believe in America oh
I'm sorry I mean wacky Halloween party
rule so we see an expecting mother
played by Diane Lane dressed up as
Helena Bonham Carter I think and it
turns out her baby is coming out much
earlier than expected several months
earlier actually too early for
contractions
doclet owner important to relax she's
fully dilated just to me all right
more different deep breath we will bring
this for his comedic plot point into the
world
till they try to figure out what made
him come out so fast and it turns out he
has a hyper rare condition most likely
caused by bad screenwriting Jax cells
are replicating at an unheard-of rate is
he gonna age like mr. esters line at age
one your son may be physically around
age four and if this continues
throughout his life by the time he
reaches age ten well he could appear to
be an ordinary full-grown forty year old
man god this explains Carlos Mencia so
well cut to a mere ten years later yeah
because I'm sure nothing interesting
happened in that amount of time no
reporters no news stories no TMZ
stalkers where we see jack is now 10 but
looks like he's about 40 so he's faced
at home being taught by his teacher Bill
Cosby who thinks it's time for him to
start going to public school I don't
think he can fit in I wish he could I
don't know what he said it would be easy
I appreciate what you're trying to do
but Brian and I we've seen how people
react we've been through this before I
just don't want Jack to have to face
that we don't want to ruin his world of
posing for posters and emotional TV ads
I know the Oscar crowd is too smart for
this manipulation but we can still try
for an Emmy
try for an Emmy as the parents think
about whether or not he should go to
public school Jack seems to be having a
bad jury you okay honey something wrong
okay just can't sleep I had a scary
dream can I sleep in here no course
buddy okay now here's the major problem
with the movie jack is not being played
like a ten-year-old he's being played
like a kindergartner and there's a huge
difference really think back to that age
do most ten-year-old boys sleep with a
doll or wear silly pajamas or sleep in
an adult's bed because they had a bad
dream
I mean look at the other 10 year olds in
this movie would you imagine any of
these kids sleeping in the bed with an
adult most toys I hear about 10 year
olds usually sleeping in adult beds end
up in incarceration the rest of the
about another good examples when the
parents decide that he should start
public school
look at this introduction how would you
like to see your classroom yes he's
little louder yes
a little louder jack just okay maybe the
kid with severe Tourette syndrome would
respond that way but this is not the
normal response for a ten-year-old
could you imagine Harry Potter reacting
this way at age 10 mr. Potter just the
things are looking up when he discovers
that his teacher is Jennifer Lopez
actually I imagine a lot of things will
be going up as soon as he discovered
that all right I know some of you must
be curious about Jack so why don't we
just take some time right now and ask
him some of the questions that you've
got on your minds come on sis when is
this group shy alright fine I've got
plenty of questions
Oh what kind of foods do you just hate
broccoli broccoli makes you smart don't
you love the kids reaction to that
broccoli broccoli makes you fart do not
approve of this broccoli line we are
here to learn why don't you go sit down
and we'll get started okay we see him
break his desk aha that you did see that
one coming in and some other looks over
old pictures of him while blowing
bubbles fortune balls um does she always
do this when she's nostalgic or is she
just high as a kite like this I won't be
to it my ten-year-old son was a
middle-aged Rhonda Williams
whenever I look over photos I like to
view them with confetti whimsy things
don't go much better when he's
approached by peppermint patty and
Marcie here can't be 10 if you shave and
you have hairy arms and you're tall
really talk and you're bigger I'm not a
freak you're a freak four-eyes
he's 10 a whole two years older than us
see oh sure like that explains it
please you're kind of like Chuck don't
you start calling me sir yeah bad little
hell really hammering in the subtlety
there with a violin aren't you Coppola
let me guess
we're supposed to feel sad hey don't
worry if you didn't get it before
there's a Randy Newman song to explain
it sad if you feel bad but if he's both
your parents were either live by or I
know
Tibbie parties wait I'm not touching
that thing his makeup terminated another
he's touched it yet I touching it
cooties really at age ten you know I
think it's common knowledge that cooties
are generally extracted after the age of
seven everybody knows this but the next
day they do find a way to use Jack to
their advantage when the bullies come
along
well we got the new kid are you crazy
suck it on the course I could whoop your
butt yeah yeah give me a high fists or
whatever we were trying to do there they
pick him for the game and of course he
does incredibly will ya do the peewee
seizure Dan's never doing that when you
were young I have a condition on top of
that some of the kids figure out they
can use him to pose as the principal to
get out of trouble with their parents or
easier yet Fran Drescher Oh sweetie
the beef in Peru only gave me ten
minutes Arthur hell does she have on I'm
sorry who's the ten-year-old in the
forty year old body so tell me what
happened to principal McGee I just
talked to him on the phone as usual
friend Drescher's voice sounds like a
series of barn animals having asthma
while smoking a box of menthols haha
really rolling a wrong oh really
rolling along really really rolling a
long way Oh what was that Christopher
Walken eating a cat Wow oh so jack is
happy that he calls his dad at work and
lets him know about his great day phone
call for you Brian
okay what the hell does this guy do for
a living you think somehow this
occupation would have worked this way
earlier into the film like to play
basketball today they picked me hey slow
down buddy slow - Louie has dirty
magazines under his bed what a dirty
magazines I got to be really sheets Mike
she's smiling at the fact that he wants
dirty magazines Oh Who am I kidding the
father's probably shooting a dirty
magazine right now it's probably for a
section called the farmer in a Dell
miss Marquez ate one of my red gummy
bears she said way to go you know but
not because of red gummy bears cuz we
okay basketball listen son I love to
talk but I got sluts on a carrot whores
on vegetables this opportunity may
strike that will not come again I gotta
be selfish sometimes I'm sorry
yeah listen dad don't hug me anymore for
the
okay yeah you know I think like you know
it's weird not like pulling your shirt
over your head while talking on the
phone but that's cool
shoot an ad lay out carrots for the
carrot board just giant carrots yeah oh
so it's an ad for carrots huh yeah I
don't think carrots have this kind of
marketing budget or at the very least
playboy style models I mean does
advertising really go this slutty for
something so mundane I don't know you
tell me
well that last long was a little slutty
okay who cares back to the review jack
gets invited to a sleepover with a bunch
of the boys in a tree house stuff
knocked over ha ha ha so you bought that
magazine yeah
what about hustler you get hustler if
you want it whoo hey check out this one
for whores on a carrot Swank that and
you know oh all the grown-up stuff that
only grown-ups can read so Jake is now
the official porn boy off to get naked
pictures free for all the young kids to
see it's like an early version of the
Internet
check this down excuse me I think our
moms look like that I did not just hear
that hey Jack you got a boner
I did not just hear that okay for a
couple of quick lesson on boys seeing
how you clearly never were one boys
don't ask about this stuff we just act
like we know it and horribly make fun of
the other dumb boys who actually asked
about this stuff and of course boys
looking at naked women is totally cool
but then when actual girls come around
and you girls cuties you you guys hold
on for one second we just want to clean
the place up a little bit okay
I'm totally isolating you because you're
different
hypocrisy thy name is Jack home he
brings his home school teacher up to the
treehouse because yeah when that make
you the cool kid sweater vests and ties
are totally in no this is enough did you
eat this mm-hmm everybody has to yet
it's good oh come on he's head where's
he's worked for jello
this house has fallen faster than my
movie career fine - oh so that entire
scene was pointless which leads to a
nice bit of awkwardness when Jack asked
Jennifer Lopez if he would go with him
to the dance I was thinking that maybe
she didn't have anything to do so you
might want to go to the dance with me
Jack you don't want to go with me I'm an
old lady but that's why I can't go with
a ghost my age because I look so much
older than them I would call the cops I
won't light it's also a little confusing
that in this world they throw a dance
for kids when apparently at this age
they're still tossing water balloons at
girls unless you want a couple of
carries loose in your room that doesn't
seem like a good idea
teachers and students don't go to dances
together do you understand that oh and
by the way their dance they're talking
about never happens because
coincidentally just at the moment of
this emotional assassination chick also
finds he's going through more growth
spurts which causes him to fall down go
boom physical signs of aging I kind of
occur more quickly his buddy's working
overtime after giving him a get-well
gift there's other things it might be
best for him to be taught at home again
we're gonna go back to the way things
were before you start at school
hey remember all the fun we had no no no
dude you're being offered not to go to
school take advantage of it
so he runs away and goes to the
nightclub that Drescher said she often
hangs out at and I'm not gonna lie the
next 20 minutes has no purpose what so
ever he talks with a guy about
relationships who looks like John
Edwards which if you've been keeping up
you shouldn't be talking to guys about
relationship to look like John Edwards
he tries to hit on Fran Drescher she
lets out of velociraptors nice and
pretty eyes he accidentally gets in a
fight with Willem Dafoe gets sent to
jail Drescher bails him out and he stays
away from public school who was the
point of all that yeah let's try this
again
let's try I think you should stay away
from public school and now he stays away
from public school all the bard Drescher
Green Goblin is not needed you can cut
this whole Posse and you won't have
missed a thing all you need to know is
that he's sad and leaving public school
is enough to get in sad
this isn't Oliver Stone's The Doors he
doesn't need to go into a deep Rockstar
depression oh oh
give me another gallon of milk don't you
think you've had enough
I'll tell you I have enough oh oh oh I
think it's time to spank the monkey Oh
Bobo you used to be my childhood friend
where are you now where are you now he's
taking everything easy for me but you're
not sorry buddy oh why did I drink the
2% so he gets depressed and never goes
outside to play with his friends
god I haven't seen him this little since
Popeye but the kids keep asking hoping
one of these days he'll finally come out
again Wow yeah come out and play he
doesn't want to we really missed the way
he called us names and threw water
balloons at us but can we have more of
that
um is this really appropriate music to
play I mean it's not like he's coming
out or feeling better he's still crying
like mad in his room this really doesn't
seem to fit do other crime scenes work
as well with this music okay but through
the magic of Thessaly I don't know
jet find the confidence to go back to
school and be with his friends again
just when his best friend is saying what
he wants to be when he grows up she
could it'd be like his best friend Jack
I want to be just like my best friend
Ryder he's like the perfect clone
because on the inside he's still just
the kid it's like he's looking at
everything for the first time he knows
how to be great friendly
more than most people
so I may not know what I want to be when
I grow up right now I really don't care
I want to be like the giant my best
friend Jack you know it's at cliched
horribly written scenes like this that
I'm sorry I really cannot believe
Francis Ford Coppola see Francis Ford
Coppola directed this maybe it needs a
killing spree
I mean you know a baptism at the end of
Godfather isn't particularly dramatic
but with a bunch of people being gunned
down it suddenly seems really heavy
let's try I'll see if the scene works
better with a killing spree I want to be
just like my best friend Ryder he's like
the perfect clone because on the inside
just the kid it's not afraid to learn
things or try things or to meet new
people the way most fonts are it's like
he's looking at everything for the first
time because he is so I may not know
what I want to be when I grew up I want
to be like the giant my best friend Jack
now it still sucks still sucks Oh for
god sake how often are the gift skip
around gigantic periods of time that
we'd actually be interested in seeing
Peabody and Sherman state in time
periods longer than this
whoa nice oh no no no no movie for
Coppola okay
guy who transformed Brando into a frail
old man half a kid a white spray paint
doesn't equal Trey old man that's not a
person who's had years and years thrown
on his life that's a bad Halloween
costume of Mark Twain the only thing
missing is a fake Gandalf beer that
really would have top things off I'm
cool here's the biggest surprise of the
movie Robin Williams gives a big speech
you know as we come to the end of this
phase of our life we find ourselves
trying to remember the good times you
know I'm convinced if you just take all
the big dramatic Robin Williams speeches
from all his movies and just put them
all together they basically just say the
same thing let's try it work where am I
gonna be in 10 years
death is not the enemy and gentlemen the
idea of someone telling me I can't feel
my kisses at all
I'm quirky which is good I fought things
and I want I'll be saying this in the
next five movies him in I'll apologize
by doing more stab ya you played a
feeling so he frights off with his
friends and that's it yeah we don't know
what happens after that we don't know if
he goes on and dies or if he makes
anything of his life just sort of stops
um did you learn anything audience any
stuff that might help you with you ever
turn into a ten-year-old trapped in a
man's body
well I've learned something I've learned
that this is the best choice that
Francis Ford Coppola has ever made since
he said hey you know what my Dracula
movie is missing one of the guys from
Ballad fucking dead
I literally feel nothing coming out of
this if it focused on him getting older
or even dying or hell how about just
getting the details about the actual age
right that may be something but as is
there's a lot of other movies that do
the little kid in the big body thing
better like big vice versa or Freaky
Friday which one of them they're both
better than this emotionally lacking
experience I mean okay
sometimes it's a little gentle and
sometimes it can have a nice scene but
it's very rare and honestly jack is not
really much of a defined character and a
lot of that is because they spend more
time on pointless scenes and obvious
humor Williams you know the Java for
COBOL chime on yo this movie deserves
what I like to call the traditional for
Coppola treatment Hail Mary
bless you
you
the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't have to
No
Wow